oh
no
a helicopter cannot fly 90 degrees on
its side like that that was crazy hey
fly peeps I am Bernice Fly Girl armor
coming at you my name is Andy Stumpf I
spent just under 17 years as a U.S Navy
SEAL my name is Admiral Jamie Fogo Peter
Rick Mike Elliott I'm Nicholas Moore
today I'll be looking at helicopter
scenes warship scenes prank battle
scenes battle wound scenes parachuting
scenes underwater action scenes from
movies and seeing how real they really
are
foreign
if you need to cross the river cross the
river you know there's no reason to
actually pop up in the middle of it and
give away your Tactical Advantage if you
are trying to sneak up on somebody you
would either cross the entire thing
above the water or cross the entire
thing below the water or or go farther
down or upstream and like you know maybe
find a log that's across it so you have
to get wet because being wet sucks
all right stop right there I had been
asked about this particular scene
so many times because people absolutely
love it and they want to know how we
train to be able to do that
and here's the answer we don't because
right you'd never fall in any other
direction you just absolutely know the
exact place and time that somebody's
gonna fall when you shoot them in the
head right because why wouldn't you what
could possibly go wrong but you gotta
remember all of that was preceded by
probably a 762 or a 300 Win Mag round
snapping Through the Jungle the
suppressor that's on the rifle it's
basically a muffler and it contains some
of the gas and it drastically reduces
the decibel output of the rifle but
bullets
when they fly through the air they're
supersonic so it makes a crack and there
is subsonic ammunition
and it's much quieter
that's not what that person was shooting
the whole point of doing the charade of
catching somebody and lowering them into
the water as if it was just eating them
into the abyss is because you're trying
to be sneaky so going through all this
and attempt to be sneaky and then
cracking off around in the jungle it
defeats the entire purpose it's just
there's so it's not how it works people
[Music]
where you link up with a submarine in
the middle of the ocean that's totally
plausible they were on a zodiac which is
going to have probably a 55 or a 35
horsepower engine so they could easily
go from a land mass Over the Horizon out
into uh International water or really
wherever the sub would want to meet and
do that so that's totally legit
yeah wow so they obviously had Direct
support from the United States Navy to
make this movie and I'm actually
surprised they showed very much of the
sdv which stands for seal delivery
vehicle in essence it is a miniature
submarine it's
smaller harder to be discovered
and you can move people and Equipment a
really far distance and then go back to
the submarine too because you can go
back and re-link back up to that asset
that you departed from you are in your
dive gear until that dive is over and it
can be up to 14 hours a lot of the times
you're in dry suits dry and warm are two
very different things that people should
not confuse they nailed it it's very
plausible that all of that would occur
on an sdb operation I'm going to give
them a 10 on that the sniper water river
catch is a zero it actually might be a
negative number
[Music]
is there a more obvious way to let
somebody know that you're coming than
white and orange parachutes in the
daytime jumping directly over the top of
them surprise you didn't see that coming
I've worn
dive fins on my feet for a free fall
jump and actually was falling through
the air with them on more often than not
though the back strap of the fin you put
your feet through that and you actually
tape the fin up to your leg but if
you're going to land in the water you're
going to want to have fins on you in
case you need to have the ability to
swim or exert yourself you're going to
need those fins
foreign
yes
and they had a fleet a full Fleet of
submersibles with spear guns I am not
aware
of any engagement at any time in the
history of human beings where anything
like this has occurred we are not trying
to get into fights in the water like
bottom line we use it as a way to
disguise what we're doing or to get from
A to B or to be sneaky right to be like
well I don't know where they went like
bloop here we are we're in the water you
didn't see a surprise we're not looking
to get into a fight ever
so no we're not bringing tridents or
spears or any of that stuff
[Music]
I like how they're cutting the uh the
hoses unfortunately there is usually an
inhalation hose and an exhalation hose
and they probably can still breathe if
they caught the wrong one we always had
dive knives on us but it's for like
cutting gear if something gets hung up
there was never a thought in my mind
ever of pulling that out with the intent
of fighting with it it was for anything
but that like Phillips head screws using
the tip of your knife like that's the
one we use dive knives for
[Music]
I like the idea of what he's got in his
mouth I'll call that the Gen 1 spare air
which with a canister of that size I
feel like you have about a one half of
one breath so he certainly wouldn't be
able to stay underwater
[Music]
concussive device in the water
concussion in the way that shock waves
travel underwater is a very very real
thing let's just say that was a grenade
of some kind that would probably kill
the people inside of that contained area
but it probably would damage him a
little bit too especially if there's
open windows and portholes because that
stuff will bounce out as well so it's
plausible but I would say you would want
to get out of there before that thing
went off like out of the water before
that thing went off uh I don't even know
if I can give this one a technical
review I found door number three
taking it
[Music]
oh that's a National Treasure all right
you know jumping off of I think it was
the aircraft carrier that's probably
going to be 50 60 feet
I'm here for that that's definitely
survivable you could definitely do that
[Music]
so we navigated with we called them nav
boards and we had three really exciting
items on there that we used to get to
stare at for hours at a time the first
one you already mentioned was a compass
the next entertaining tool was a depth
gauge and lastly a stopwatch that was it
we dive in pairs but only one person
gets the navigation board so somebody
else out there is just like I hate my
life this dive is taking forever I don't
even have anything to look at so
sometimes when I was the buddy I would
just swim on top of my dive buddy and
just look at the navigation board too
because I was so bored I just wanted to
look at numbers slowly just like
creeping around
gates in the water sir it's the Hudson
nothing is visible
so all these people that are above them
looking down are going to see the
bubbles this would be an example of
where a closed circuit would be better
than open circuit because even though
that guy grabbed him right underwater
every time they exhale the bubbles are
coming up it's actually really easy to
track diver's progress from above when
they're breathing open circuit open
circuit you can see the bubbles closed
circuit you can be sneaky it's just a
closed loop system that only allows the
gas to flow through in One Direction
because obviously you wouldn't want it
coming back and forth and you push it
through a chemical scrubber it pulls out
the carbon dioxide and boom you're off
and running there's 100 chance that you
could actually do that but if you wanted
to do it and actually not be seen I'd
say closed circuit is a better option
I'll give them a
seven hi my name is Peter Rhee I served
in the military for 24 years and I'm a
trauma surgeon I was one of the first
surgeons in Afghanistan today we're
going to be looking at Battle wound
scenes
[Applause]
what they're trying to show is an
evisceration so a guy got hit they're
taking enemy fire High Velocity weapons
AK-47s out there getting hit and then
you eviscerate your organs they're
making an attempt to push it back and
you can't do it it doesn't work that way
the ones I saw were from Exit Wounds of
AK-47s through a little small plum sized
hole you will shove everything up
because you got pressure as a grunting
and moaning from the pain and then you
can't shove it back in because it just
pops right back out so unless they're
chemically Paralyzed by intubating them
it's a waste of time in penetrating
injury when we're talking about bullet
wounds and so on like that the main
thing is just get them to me as soon as
you can and stop the bleeding if it's
not your heart and your major vessels we
can save you if you don't hit those the
rest we can repair hey look at me
now the one thing I hate when they do
movies is every time you get some sort
of torso injuries they make them spit
blood and that doesn't happen unless you
get shot in the mouth or you have
something going through your cheeks and
your throat up high you don't vomit
blood from getting a gut shot or
anything like that
the one thing I do like is they do show
how difficult it is to move a heavy body
out there these are two to three hundred
pound
masses that you gotta drag and two guys
pulling these things is not that easy to
do I think that part's all done
you'd never drop in a bird when there's
fire going on a bird's not going to come
down to go do a casualty evacuation when
they're gonna be shooting at a 40
million dollar bird up in the air the
lonely Land one is a really secured
Landing Zone I'd give it about a six
priority
it's a great movie it's it's pretty well
done the triage in the field is very
different than triage when you come to a
medical company you're not doing so much
of this actually during the heat of the
battle itself it's usually once the the
initial firefight gets done there's four
categories when we triage so he went
through all four of them dead expectant
they need your help and then they're
okay the guy's hollering and yelling if
they're yelling they're okay so it's a
routine and then then he had one guy
that's a priority and then the guy was
already dead confirming someone that's
dead in few seconds is not easy to do I
was in ramadi when we had a 200 people
that were bombed at one time from one
bomb we got 70 of these casualties that
came right to us just coming in and they
all come in one by one and that was the
triage officer the first Marine I got
was expecting but but I couldn't tell
for sure because I only had literally
four or five seconds to decide whether
he was dead or not and there was no way
we could use our resources to work in
endemic so what you're doing is trying
to cherry pick the easy saves so you
don't want to spend too much time on it
which is very different than what we do
in civilian trauma in civilian trauma we
go full bore Hardcore team of 12 on top
of one person for hours and hours and uh
that's not something you can do in the
military I give it a nine I stay with me
what happens is that Kirk
there's some realism in there this is an
outpost this looks like Army so Army
Italian base station Army will usually
have a medic or they'll have a
physician's assistant usually with as
much webbing and stuff the unit that
they're in the housing unit and this is
paper thin so the bullets will go right
through there they should be a little
bit more fortified with the Hesco
barriers of dirt you notice that the guy
is bagging a guy because he's not
breathing well and they're about to do
CPR we don't do that out there if they
need CPR that's wasting time because
they need blood Medevac will be here for
a few hours which means needs fresh
blood if he wants to live this is the
only thing we can do in our style we
can't test for disease our fresh blood
is all we can do to say gloves again
with a bloody hands that's not really
realistic they have gloves at this point
when I went out there we started doing
this for the first time we actually
started to really use warm fresh whole
blood which is miraculous it's
unbelievably miraculous we can't do that
in the civilian world but we did walking
Blood Bank in my unit in a ramadi
Charlie Med to surgeon shop we had about
60 70 Medics with us as well the base
was about 600 people so we'd go to the
chow hall and there would be a guy that
screams out walking Blood Bank everybody
would spit out their food go line up at
my medical company check their dog tags
they lay down on the floor they would
poke them get a bag of blood we would do
a little test to see if they were
compatible when we used it so from that
perspective it's true there's a lot of
little mistakes that they made through
here and in order to dramatize so they
can get away with it for most people but
you know you would be walking up to them
and giving them your blood standing up
and things like that at least they were
in the right uniform so I give them
seven
[Applause]
this is a really good scene when that
explosion went off in slow motion you
could see the boot flying right at the
camera it's a little bit unusual from an
injury point of view a shell to coming
in hitting the ground would take his
legs off like that because that seeing
bilateral amputees at the thigh has been
a really recent injury that we never saw
before in previous Wars we didn't really
see bilateral amputations above the knee
before the other war movies they would
step on Claymores and landmines and
those were actually meant to take off
your foot and your ankle so the Medics
would come out and then you'd sniper the
Medics and get more casually so it
wasn't really supposed to be a mortal
wound his was mangled below the knee but
obviously his was going to be close to
what we were seeing in Iraq where they
would just build these huge bombs and
bury them into the ground we were seeing
just legs blown Sky High
I could do three hours on tourniquets
blood loss is the number one preventable
loss that we want to avoid some of the
soldiers they even wear tourniquets uh
when they're going out there actually
what we are recommending and what we
teach is that they put on your own
tourniquets the tourniquets are
problematic because if you don't put it
on right and if it's not on absolutely
the tightest it can be you'll bleed more
and you'll bleed out when you put it on
you got to commit to it you got to go
full board and I tell you putting a
turning coat on will be the most painful
thing you experienced about three to
four minutes it's like your leg is
falling off so it is something you do as
a last resort it will save lives but
you've got to go for it otherwise it
will actually bleed more
here comes the morphing here comes the
morphine
it's gonna kick in real quick bro we're
gonna get you shifted in the old days uh
morphine was good we got scared of it
because morphine can definitely kill you
if you take a person who's low blood
pressure not a blood circulating and
then you give it then it can depress
your or your cardiac function and then
you can die you would also stop
breathing so we've actually gone away
from morphine in the field we use a new
drug called ketamine while it provides a
lot of relief of pain it does not lower
your blood pressure so that's the reason
why we use it the Medics can do a lot
and they're so vitally important but a
lot of the movies uh is I think the
audience doesn't understand that a medic
is not a trauma surgeon trauma surgeon
obviously went to medical school did uh
five years of general surgery then two
years of training as a trauma surgeon so
seven years of training like a brain
surgeon the medic's job is to get them
to us not to clamp things in the field
it's pretty good I'd say give it a nine
my name is Admiral Jamie Fogo and I
served in the Navy for almost 40 years
when I retired I took over as Dean
Center for maritime strategy of the Navy
League here in Washington DC today we're
going to be looking at warship scenes
from movies
Greyhound is an absolutely phenomenal
movie it tells and depicts with great
historical accuracy the Germans are
depicted in the movie as deploying the
wolf pack tactics and you know you see
two Torpedoes coming from different
directions you know that's more than one
submarine firing and these tactics were
extremely effective
so what you see on the bridge of the
ship is an attack on the Destroyer you
know I think that was very realistic and
you see the wake of the torpedo coming
towards you the propellers do something
that we call cavitate they create
Bubbles as they're going through the
water and that creates a trail behind
the torpedo and so a sharp Lookout can
pick that up early and it gives the
commanding officer an advantage to
conduct those uh drastic evasive
maneuvers if it was nighttime a lot of
times it's even easier to see the
torpedo because of the phosphorescence
in the water it kind of glows as it's
coming at you a lot of these Torpedoes
were electric powered they had batteries
and electric motors in them and they
would go towards the target nowadays we
have Torpedoes that are propelled by
Fuel and have a very long range and so
it was a different game back then but in
this case absolutely accurate
as far as the maneuverability is
concerned of that Destroyer you have to
keep in mind this is not a battleship
that displaces 50 000 tons these are
lighter ships nowadays uh heavy
destroying the United States Navy's
about 7 800 8 000 tons the propulsion
systems on these destroyers the engines
and the propellers and the Rudders Are
Made For Speed and maneuverability
particularly because in the Second
Battle of the Atlantic they were not
only going after surface ships they were
going after submarines and that means
you've got to be able to turn on a dime
the rounds that actually hit the water
or penetrate the water whether or not
they actually do any damage it depends
as soon as uh you know a 50 caliber
round uh hits water typically ricochets
if it does go beneath the water line you
lose velocity very quickly so it's
highly unlikely that that would
penetrate any kind of Steel haul but
again you never know
so he has to surface because water's
coming in and then Wally's on the
surface they finish him off in pretty
much of a brutal manner but you see what
looks like anti-aircraft guns that are
lowered to the deck plate level is this
projectile went in and it blew up it may
have caused secondary explosions first
there's an initial boom and then a
massive boom there's so much oil and
fuel and weapons on board that submarine
that you know once it took that initial
penetration of the hull and those shape
charges went in and exploded this movie
gets absolutely top marks for me as far
as realism 10 out of 10. cradle lowered
I know Ram the projectile easy
when you ram that powder you ram it easy
real easy
this is one of the most accurate movies
on how you load a 16-inch projectile
into a 16 inch barrel that projectile
weighs 2 000 pounds so you're
essentially uh loading a Volkswagen
Beetle into the breach of that gun and
firing it at the enemy and you notice
that the projectile it's followed by
these powder charges this was a very
accurate representation of how you load
that gun there are spark proof tools and
everybody is very careful because you
know that powder is obviously explosive
and volatile in any mistake or any spark
or any flame could set it off and blow
up that turret zero four degrees
Callaway
two zero four degrees zero four degrees
very shiny brass device that's a gun
sight and that's to allow the gun
Captain uh to take a look out and see
the direction that he's firing in that's
the way uh that we used to do it before
we had these very sophisticated Fire
Control Radars and gun directors that
are on top of the turrets today by fire
in the hole
I I got a chuckle out of the fact that
Tommy Lee Jones runs toward the 16-inch
gun turret just before it's fired we had
on the battleships procedures to prevent
Sailors from being topside in proximity
to those turrets when they fire the guns
because the overpressure the blast uh
blew him back you know uh a dozen or so
feet and that's probably fairly accurate
even today with uh our missile systems
if you're launching from the four deck
of Destroyer nobody's up there when
you're launching because there's going
to be a lot of flash to bang as the
weapon comes out of the tube and you
don't want anybody to get hurt I'd give
it a 7 out of 10.
Battleship happens to be uh one of my
favorite movies these are World War II
era ships they're not part of the active
Fleet anymore but these ships are made
to fight and when you're on one of those
battleships and you have a belt of armor
around you 12 to 17 inches thick and 50
000 tons of steel to protect you
that's pretty reassuring
awesome
the deck on the bridge uses uh the
anchor on the battleship to avoid
getting hit by some of the aliens
weapons uh frankly that's pretty hokey
the amount of chain on a battleship or
an aircraft carrier uh connected to the
Anchor is uh is pretty long you know
it's probably at least a thousand feet
but we don't use anchors for that reason
we use anchors to Moor the ship in Port
and this is in the Pacific Ocean which
is really deep
foreign
thing that the viewers might not notice
is it's so powerful that the ship
actually moves sideways several yards
when you fire a broadside it can move
significantly and you have to do a
course correction there I'd probably
give it a two I think Hollywood took a
little poetic license on the anchor in
this case hey fly peeps I am Bernie's
flag girl armor coming at you and back
in 2003 I became America's first black
female combat pilot serving two tours in
Iraq today I'll be looking at helicopter
scenes and movies
flying in formation and helicopters is
very common we practice it a lot we will
land together we'll take off together
and in an environment like this where
you have that mission where you're
dropping off say a flight of soldiers
and in this case yeah that would
absolutely happen like that
just everything about that combat
maneuver the insertion them dropping
that's why we don't do static things
like that anymore in combat because of
the vulnerability and the the helicopter
has pretty much no maneuverability when
you're in that close to be able to get
out really quick a helicopter just
doesn't move quick a helicopter has to
build up momentum and and get going
right RPGs are a huge threat to
helicopters especially if we're flying
what we call low and slow but I remember
flying in combat and we just saw the and
it was early on in combat and I just saw
these great clouds of mist and we were
trying to figure out like what are those
clouds of Miss and they were RPGs that
had been programmed to explode at 200
and 300 feet and some of my buddies were
impacted by RPGs huge threat
foreign
I would say unrealistic part of that
clip when that RPG hit the tail rotor of
that aircraft I thought it would have
been spinning a lot faster and it wasn't
gliding down without power and at the
very end if he tried to cushion The
Landing a little bit which we're taught
to do in that kind of situation with a
loss of tail rotor we would have tried
to circle around in the direction that
it's spinning to have a little control
but it wouldn't have just landed flat
like you saw in that video so the guys
in the back hopefully they're tied in or
they would just immediately be thrown
out just like a car accident that Twirls
over and everybody gets ejected out of
the vehicle the reason I think they show
or film more helos getting hit in the
tail rotor just because it's more
dramatic you get hit in the tail rotor
you're immediately going to start
spinning and go out of control if you
get hit in the main rotor you just
explode and fall out the sky which one's
more exciting on a scale of one to ten
nine
foreign
helicopters is that realistic absolutely
I had a 20 millimeter Gatling gun three
Barrel it um rolled around and delivered
lots of bullets very fast on target so
yes 100 realistic only the pilots would
fire that weapon
you see two rocket launchers left right
then two missile launchers left and
right there are 26 rockets in each one
of those pods then there are four
missiles on the inboard that is actually
a standard payload for an attack
helicopter
the Rockets are called 2.75 inch Rockets
so they're about this big around right
2.75 inches and they're pretty long the
Rockets are just like bullets you you
aim you shoot you pull they go wherever
wind shear impacts them the Hellfire
missiles are laser guided right so
they're Guided by a laser to a
particular Target a rocket it impacts a
small area let's say it's 20 feet 30
feet these Rockets are basically just
you know as soon as they hit they
explode and it's a point target the
missile has a lot more explosive power
to it you could shoot a tank or a
building it's going to explode there are
heat seeking missiles and missiles that
can fly to catch a jet per se right but
those aren't the kind of missiles that
number one were on this aircraft and
number two aircraft helicopters don't
normally carry them and
they don't
follow humans and I doubt his jet pack
had enough heat coming off because it
probably would have burned up his legs
if that were the case
[Music]
there would have been no way they could
just glide into
um going through the vortices of the
helicopter I could easily see them being
blown down 50 to 100 feet just like that
the payload that was actually realistic
the heat seeking missiles not so much
I'm gonna give it a seven
you can't fly through something like
that
unrealistic
rotors would have already fallen off the
aircraft as hard as rotor blades look
they're very sensitive and finely tuned
and balanced and as soon as it impacts
an object you're not going to be able to
fly the aircraft after that
because it's the rock could have been
realistic with him hanging on the side
just like hanging on to a car right
because most of the downward push of the
Wind from a helicopter is on the last
third of the blades it's not in the in
the very center so the wind shear
wouldn't have pushed them out of The
Middle
totally unrealistic it's just like the
wheel of a car it's never in one
position it's constantly moving where to
get the piece of metal to even fix it
when they showed it in that clip it was
just stable he's actually able to hold
it in the rod and it's just not going to
be stable like that
no a helicopter cannot fly 90 degrees on
its side like that that's crazy I would
give it a one greetings all I'm Nicholas
Moore and I commission is an armor
officer on M1 tanks and then M3 Bradleys
these days I work as a civilian
historian for the publisher of World of
Tanks today we're going to be looking at
tank battle scenes
ready
and that is absolutely accurate the vast
majority of tanks that were destroyed
had no idea that the enemy was there and
again this is why you always have to
work in conjunction with infantry
because they have more eyes than you do
they have better Vision than you do but
more often than not the first indication
that somebody is there is when you get
shot at and knocking off either the
first or the last tank in an ambush in a
row like that is classic
with regard to the TC's in this case
keeping their heads out there are two
schools of thought but certainly in the
time period of World War II all the way
through the Cold War even myself it
would be in a head out positions the
Western school of thought is you keep
your head out because what you don't see
will kill you the other school of
thoughts such as used by the Soviet Army
in the Cold War was that you wanted to
operate head down so you close the hatch
no artillery could affect you no snipers
could affect you
and the problem of course is the reverse
you aren't able to see whatever is about
to kill you
so there is a balance to be struck
all right I'll take
it
what Daddy has decided for some reason
that he is going to charge the enemy
tank I'm not sure I would have done
quite the same thing because that
simplifies the problem for the enemy and
just give him three Targets in a line if
you can uh have it's called a base of
fire and then a maneuver element then
the enemy tank has a choice he can
engage the guy that's uh just sitting
there pumping accurate shots at you or
the German tank can Engage The flanking
element who are coming around the side
and the 76 millimeter gun on two of
these tanks actually would destroy a
tiger
okay so being obscured the German tank
has decided to advance out of the smoke
as opposed to just sit there and wait
for whatever the enemy were going to do
the Germans were very very big on
individual initiative the concept is
called austral's tactic these days as we
use a development of it called Mission
command but the bottom line is you don't
wait for orders you take the initiative
you make a decision on the spot and that
is exactly what the German has done here
the reticle is accurate for a World War
II American Tank and shy in this case is
using the coaxial telescope so you're
going to see graduations on the reticle
each graduation is for a type of round
at a certain range so if your target is
let's say 800 yards you will Elevate the
gun so that the 800 yard graduation is
on the target so the single biggest
cause of missing in World War II was
range estimation error if you get the
range wrong it doesn't matter if your
aim is correct you will go over or short
which is why we now have modern Fire
Control Systems to do all that
mathematics for you
and what
if you're in this sort of a knife fight
which I wouldn't recommend getting into
in the first round set the engine alive
but that doesn't necessarily say that
the tank crew and the turret can't still
get a shot off do you say you shoot at a
tank until it burns or changes shape so
keep shooting until you know that the
threat is gone this scene is an easy
nine what Fury lacks in perhaps some of
the technical accuracy it more than
makes up for an understanding the
experience of being a tank crewman
this is absolutely correct there's gun
Crews on each side of the sponson the
tank is based off of a Mark 8
International which was a very late
World War one tank built by both the UK
and us and at the time British tanks the
heavy tanks had what were called sponson
guns the turret that wasn't on the mark
8.
zombies shouting instructions to each
other wouldn't happen it's too loud and
they cite a World War one tank the
entire middle of that tank was taken up
by the engine it was massive noise what
he's doing there he's using hand signals
that's the only way to communicate
inside a World War one tank
[Music]
firing a gun with anything in the barrel
is bad you're under risk of exactly what
happened here it's called pedaling and
when the gun barrel just pedals out like
a flower and your gun is done oftentimes
you'll see a tank will have a rubber
muzzle cap on the end purely to stop any
dirt at all from getting into it and
it's designed that you can actually
shoot through the muzzle cap
to my knowledge on tank fighting has
never been trained in any army
personally I'd have just stuck my head
at the top used a pistol but again not
very dramatic and it will kind of suck
for Indy I would have to give the scene
maybe a three on feasibility grounds
a tiger has appeared on the scene tiger
had a mythical status in World War II it
had a reputation because it was very
very hard to kill
and because it had a heck of a gun the
8.8 centimeter was Lethal to basically
everything the problem was that it looks
very much like a Panzer 4 which is a lot
more common in actuality historians have
found very few times on the Western
Front that American soldiers ever
actually met a tiger but for the
purposes of drama a tiger is fine
this was pretty realistic drivers are
absolutely blind inside their tanks and
they're utterly reliant on instructions
from the commander so that's how you get
up close to a tank low below the line of
vision below the the level of depression
that the guns can aim at you
we're going for the wheels because the
tiger was a breakthrough tank it was
heavily armored everywhere and if you're
infantry and you don't have high
velocity cameras your best bet is to
disable the tank and get what's called a
Mobility kill to immobilize the tank
your two choices are going to be either
the engine compartment or the running
gear and the only thing that these
sticky bombs are going to have any
particular effect on will be the running
gear so the sticky bomb it was in the
manual but it is also almost a weapon of
desperation the military is supposed to
give you tools for the job late World
War II array you're talking about the
Bazooka now the problem is that you only
have so many rounds of bazooka
ammunition and a bazooka is only so
effective against something as heavily
armored as a tiger so you're in
desperation mode to start with
so now we see one of the problems with a
tank going on its own a tank shouldn't
go on its own for several reasons but
when you have infantry and infestation
we might like to say as tankers crawling
on your tank there's a process that's
called scratching your friend's back
what you do is you get on the radio you
call your buddy with a machine gun and
he will machine gun your tank of course
the bullets aren't going to affect your
tank you're in a tank but it will very
much clean off or delouse the Infantry
that are crawling on your tank
[Applause]
and that's your example of delousing so
the 20 millimeter anti-aircraft gun like
any anti-aircraft gun with a high rate
of fire you aim that thing horizontally
and you will do a number on Infantry if
there's any big myth about tanks it's
probably that there are these
invulnerable fortresses in reality
they're not invulnerable at all and
they're absolutely reliant on the other
parts of the combined arms team you have
the desperation of lightly armed
infantry you have this back scratching
you have the immobilization of a very
dangerous tank I mean this is easily
under nine scale hi I'm Mike Elliott a
26 year combat veteran I served 11 years
with the US Army golden Knight parachute
team I have over 16
000 skydives six thousand tandems 100
static line jumps and about 20 military
Free Fall jumps today we're going to be
looking at parachuting scenes in movies
so I think he did the correct procedures
with military Free Fall jumpers with
combat equipment they have their O2
Milestone goggles it's a lot of moving
parts so there is a possibility that
something should come loose I mean it
takes about 15 seconds to fix this O2
pipe and put it back to his helmet you
can hold your breath up to a minute and
still be okay so he had plenty of time
to fix his Mast and still leave the
aircrafts
his body position is very correct here
he's in what we call a die position and
it is so Uber important to have the
correct body position basically you have
to learn how to push air with your body
so the wind is basically hitting around
his waist and chest area which allows
that wind to be symmetrical around his
body so he can gain stability after he
exes the yakrapy
they did a very great job as a Halo
jumper basically Halo is high high
altitude low opening meaning you exited
aircraft above 15 000 feet you have to
have some type of breeding breathing
apparatus in the aircraft as well as on
your body as far as the form is
concerned there's no different form with
Halo it's called the the box man
position or the Arts position everything
he's doing in this scene is done
correctly your knees are bent your
pelvis is pushed forward your arms are
are back
that is a really gnarly looking storm I
have never had to jump into clouds and
lightning and it's not even approved by
the Federal Aviation Administration with
clowns you cannot see the ground and you
can get struck by lightning and if
you're flying with other jumpers now
you're at a risk of running into another
person and when you slam into another
person at 120 miles per hour it's going
to be some serious injuries
I I do like that the body position of
both actors in this movie are correct
and if you're unconscious and you're
going to be on your back because your
arms and legs are the lowest portions of
your body so gravity will put you on
your back I would rate this
um a high seven for sure all those are
very unique Maneuvers that could
possibly happen
thank you
a total high five on this scene from the
ramp to the exit with the military Free
Fall operation
um each group this excellent aircraft
has a team leader and your guide and all
the guys so they're grouping around him
so they can see what's going on and
that's the same formation they stay in
during their exit and as they get out
into free fall
as you see here they jump in at night
time everything gets really really
difficult at night time because either
flying through nods are just with your
naked eye and you can't see obstacles
you can't see the ground coming up and
in the Army you have the round static
line jumps from like the 82nd or one
Division and you have the Army parachute
team which are demonstrations and
competitive type guys on the Special
Operation side in U.S Navy uh seals or
Delta Force or Special Forces these guys
are trained to put that parachute where
they need to put it to do what they need
to do best so if these guys are
illustrating from a spec ops side uh yes
that is something that can can
definitely be done
[Music]
in this particular scene they're doing a
Halo special operation soldiers their
thing is to be as stealthy and as quiet
and as dark as they can and the premise
of a Halo jump is soldiers could step
out up to 40 or 50 miles away at 25 000
feet open their Parachute by 20 000 feet
and they can drift in quietly steadily
undetected from miles away for this I
don't know why they would have smokes
best of all you can't see smoke at night
time it's mandatory to have blinking
lights on your body on your flying at
night time so other aircraft could see
you Special Operation guys they're not
going to have any lights and flares
because they're coming in as steadfully
as quiet as possible so they can do the
mission uh once they get on the ground
The Landing as you see it's an extremely
tight area the tight parachutes that a
military special op guys it's called
mc4's mc5s very big very docile
parachutes they definitely can land on
buildings and in tight areas I don't
think they would land in something not
tight not a bad looking clip at all I
would give them a six okay
put your grip and hold on is virtually
impossible that parachute is designed
for one person and you're not hooked up
properly as if you're doing a tandem but
if I knew there was a possibility that
person could say both our lives then I
would make that that attempt to do that
I was trying to to look and see what
their all terminal reading was and I
couldn't really see I see it's flashing
low altitude but we have no idea of how
low they are before they open up their
main parachute 2500 feet is when you
open up your main parachute takes time
for those things to fully and open with
today's parachute systems we have what
we call an automatic opening device it's
going to open up the reserve parachute
for you and that is designed to open at
a low altitude so your main parachute
which they were using in this scene they
could open up at that lower altitude is
not very realistic
to have someone attached to you and land
on a Target that's not doing a tandem
absolutely impossible it's called
parachute accuracy two people under one
parachute somebody's gonna break some
ankles for sure in that case they should
have did what we call a a parachute
Landing fall where you hit the balls on
your feet cab thighs and your buttocks
which is the softest part of your body
so trying to land and roll to those soft
sides of your body is kind of what they
did in this scene
um but there's just no way that you can
even see around that person enough to
fly that parachute to a Target area I'm
gonna rate these guys at a five
wow I mean every time I I see a static
line operation at this depth it gives me
chill bumps to think about
um soldiers in World War II the
forefathers of parachuting with static
line jumping it's the most expedient way
to put soldiers on the battlefield if
you look at some of the actual footage
that happened on D-Day and Market
Gardens that's basically what you see
numerous numerous parachutes in the air
at any given time
so this is absolutely 100 correct I was
actually an Airborne instructor for
three years where I trained parachutes
how to become paratroopers and uh the
best way to get off the aircraft is
basically you're pushing a guy in front
of you out the door so you can get out
the door as quick as possible and as you
exit you get into a good tight body
position which is your hands over your
harness feet knees together and that
static line actually pulls your
parachute out and your pressure opens
automatically I'm gonna rate this as a
10. I'm just amazing any and every time
I see what the guy's done for us back in
World War II if you enjoyed this video
why not click on the video above